[Music]
Hi, I'm Lizzie. I'm a developer advocate
at Cloudflare. And I'm Nick. I'm a
developer experience engineer at work
OS. Yes. So, at Cloudflare, I make a lot
of AI demos, AI MCP servers. Anyone here
also making any of those? Yes. Agents.
Nice. Of course, should have guessed
because conference. So, I've been having
fun making agents and MCP servers that
act on behalf of me. I built an agent to
auto vote in the NBA finals for me and
then I got blocked eventually. Uh,
anyways, like book tennis courts in San
Francisco cuz Lord knows that is hard
enough to do already. So, I think that's
like a great agent use case. agent that
acts for me automate some of the tedious
parts of my life, things that I want to
do. However, that does beg the question,
how do you control what they're allowed
to do?
Yeah. And we're we're moving so fast
with all of this and having fun getting
it to do things. You know, GitHub MCP is
like one of my favorites because I can
just like get it going and and uh have
it like read reviews for me, read diffs
for me, and and uh just help me manage
GitHub. uh which is really awesome but
it's very like developer centric
obviously it's GitHub but MCPs in
general like you have to go and edit
this like JSON file and do that and it's
really tough to to like I have to give
it a pat and you know that's that's an
advanced use case for non-developers
uh and so we really need a way to let
these tools act on our behalf uh but in
a more traditional way that's easy for
for end users to be able to set that up
and um so yeah that that's what We do
work OS. Uh we we do like authorization
and user management. And like the the
main point of this talk is to really
help uh drive the idea that we need like
the same kind of credentials and uh
authorization that we do with userf
facing projects. We need the agents to
do that as well as a start and then we
have a lot of places that we can go with
this as we get more fine grained. Um but
really the the point is that oath really
just isn't for humans anymore. It's for
our agents acting on our behalf.
And you know what else agents need?
Memory, persistent storage.
Anyone here use Cloudflare?
You think you know what Cloudflare does?
No. I'm here to tell you that you do
not.
People are like, "Oh, you do security,
CDN, DOS protection, bot management. We
do so much more. We have compute cloud
workers. We can host your code on the
edge. Uh we host AI models. You can run
inference on uh vectorized. We have a
vector database, a SQL database, durable
objects which is what we use in our
agents framework to maintain memory.
Very important.
And video streaming, image optimization,
so much more. If you use Cloudflare
workers, we have bindings. Bindings let
you interact from your web app, from
your website, from your agent as well
because our agents and MCB servers are
kind of similar in that you can use
bindings to interact with other
Cloudflare products. And also just like
of course you can use other companies
products as well. And of course now we
have a free tier. Durable optics used to
not be free. Now you can use it. And I
know startups who use Cloudflare who do
not pay us and they make money. I
digress. But yeah, all of these pieces,
they really help to um like they just
fit naturally into building these agents
because they'll deliver the code to
where you're at. Uh and you can use the
durable objects to store persistence on
them. Uh and you can also use things uh
like like authorization to um make sure
and there's a whole ooth framework with
uh Cloudflare's uh agents framework that
lets you set up that authorization so
that you can easily uh know who the
worker is or the agent is acting on
behalf of. Yeah.
So and this agenda will be made
available at the end in the GitHub repo.
It's a markdown file.
So we we did build uh an MCP server uh
using Cloudflare and using work OS and
uh it's just a very basic one. You'll be
able to check it out and you can use it
and run it today. Uh which is really
awesome. Um and we we're just going to
deploy it real quick. So I'll just do um
npm run uh deploy which will run
Wrangler to deploy that. And soon as
it's out there uh we'll be able to see
it in my uh in my compute here. Oops, I
was just there. That's the Cloudflare
dashboard and it's also very easily to
run locally as well with like npm run or
wringler run something similar. So a few
seconds ago uh we've got it deployed and
going back to the terminal it gave me a
URL
here and so I can just copy my workers
URL and I'm going to go over to my
client claude and I'm just going to hit
this button and say add integration and
it's going to pop up. I'll make this
big. Uh, and I can go add integration.
And I'll just say I want to add
MCP.shop.
What could it be? Naming themes is hard.
Just tacking on it. Slmmcp onto there.
And now I've got MCP shop. And I'm going
to connect. And so once I connect, uh,
this is pulling up and allowing me to
tell the agent, uh, who to act on behalf
of, me in this case. Uh, so I'm going to
sign in with GitHub. It's going to
do its thing and then cloud or uh sorry
cloud is refreshed and now it can act on
behalf of me and can we see the tools?
Yeah.
So what should we ask?
Let's order a shirt. Let's order a
shirt. I love shirts.
Yo, I hear I can get a shirt. get a
shirt from you.
Live demos in an LL.
Wi-Fi don't fail us.
So, it's running and it recognized that
it has tools available now from MCP
shop. So, it's going to list the
inventory. We'll go ahead and let it
run.
Yeah, there's an MCP shirt. You can get
it for free. Uh, and you can pick your
size. And then all it needs is just your
company name and your mailing address.
And so I'll say give me
uh I'll say XL and one two three Main
Street
uh Belleview, Nebraska. There's a
building, Nebraska. Uh and we'll do
that.
Oh, it needs my company name.
That's so linked in. Duh.
Might be my company name is work OS duh
now.
So, let that run.
I was sure thinking about it. It's
confirmed it.
Done. And there's my order number. It's
going to be sent to that address. And
I'm going to say
what uh is the order info so I can see
what uh is my name or my company name
works. Duh.
Kind of hope it is. Human in the loop.
Need to confirm.
No, I got it. A right.
That was totally me, not Claude.
Uh, so yeah, I was able to order a shirt
and you can as well. But that's just a
piece of it. So when we ran this, um,
it's going into close that. Uh, if we go
into my Cloudflare platform here and go
to storage KV, I've got an orders here.
This is key value storage. Yep. And
there is the data
from the order. So now I've got that
saved off. I can use that Uh, and it was
all through that interface. So, we
really just like gave Claude the tools
that it needed and it was able to act on
my behalf. And I can go back in and I
can say like, "Can you tell me what you
know about me?"
And this
so we've got a get user info. And this
is really just going to give me like
mostly the the jot information. What's
on my my JWT uh that Claude now knows
about me. So it knows my name. It knows
my email address. In my jot I have my
favorite song in there. Um Careless
Whisper. Uh now I will give you a
rendition. Uh and so um from there it
also knows that I have admin
permissions. Uh so I've shot admin
access because that's in my roles and
permissions.
The the other cool thing that you can do
uh with like the cloudflare piece of it
and because like your your MCP server is
a um durable object, you can also store
data like directly on that that's that's
located on that. You want to explain
that durable objects tough name. If you
search Twitter, people tweet about how
they're like, "This is a bad name.
Change the name." But very fast storage.
You can spin them up per user. Uh
they're close to the user as well for
like faster retrieval and storage.
And so what I did is I just asked it to
change the demo mode to band. And that
ran a tool uh in the MCP server itself
that is uh just going in and on the uh
context that's associated with this
worker object, it's just changing the
mode to band. And so now I've got that
and now I can say um I want another
shirt, please.
And it's going to try and run it.
I'll just always allow that now.
And it was able to check that and it
said absolutely not. Go away wave.
Um and so like we can mix what it knows
about me with what it has stored about
me on the durable object and that's in
unique for every user of it. And then uh
I can do things like uh change it again.
So if I say pretty please it might have
a pretty please tool available. Sure
is thinking. Yay. Since I asked nicely,
it's going to let me. And I just ordered
another shirt. Prompt engineering.
If you want to build your own MCP
servers on Cloudflare, you can click to
deploy your own with no authorization.
So it's offless. So probably don't do
that, but it is very quick to do so. You
click click to deploy. It generates a
GitHub repo for you. You get clone that
and then you edit your own tools and
they give you some tools to begin with.
So it's like very fast but again that is
oless do o and it's still quick to
deploy as well with o just like slightly
less fast. Yeah and the the beauty of
this is that we're bringing the like you
know pretty simple tools like this is
just a flow being added to an MCP and
MCP is effectively just an API. Uh so
we're just like you know getting it
caught up with the tools that we already
have uh for humans but it's important to
get this uh ready to go for these tools
to act on our behalf as well. And where
we can see this going in the future is
like much more fine grained
authorization where it's maybe like
authorizing you know per line changes or
or per tool changes or even like maybe
like authorizing like the networks uh
the connections between things and just
doing as we see it growing to doing
thousands of of tasks on our behalf.
This off piece is going to be very
important. uh and especially the audit
trail as well. And we can get that with
with O tools too just to make sure that
like we can see why this interacted this
way on whose behalf was it on and what
was the end result where did it fail uh
where did it go wrong things like that.
Think of your users not as users but as
deputies they have access to tools and
they can use and also misuse them as
well. Sometimes I think I trust people
like I do a live demo and I'm like let's
see user um input. People sometimes do
not nice inputs.
Yeah. So get out there and deputize your
own tools. Um we'll we have this repo
available. There is the code uh a QR
code for this repo. Also the top QR code
is get your own shirt. A shirt. Yeah. Uh
so or you can just go to mcp.shop shop,
uh, which you will run the same workflow
that I just ran. Uh, it doesn't have the
pretty police tool in it, though. Uh,
unfortunately, it'll just it'll just do
it even if you're mean to it. Uh, but
you can order a shirt for the low low
price of $0. So, go check it out. Get an
MCP t-shirt. And if you want to add your
own pretty please tool, check out the
code in the second curo code. And we
can't wait to see what MCP servers you
build with O. Thank you. Thank you.
[Music]